Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Finally, today, DeepMind’s amazing AI,
MuZero that plays Chess and other games
has now finally entered the real world and has
learned to solve important real-world problems.
This is a reinforcement learning technique that
works really well on games. Why? Well, in Chess,
Go and Starcraft, the controls are clear, we use
the mouse to move our units around or choose where
to move our pieces. And the score is also quite
clear: we get rewarded if we win the game. That
is going to be our score. To say that these worked
really well would be an understatement: DeepMind’s
MuZero is one of the best in the world in Chess,
Go, and Stacraft 2 as well. But one important
question still remains. Of course, they did not
create this AI to play video games. They created
it to be able to become a general-purpose AI
that can solve not just games, but many problems.
The games are just used as an excellent
testbed for this AI. So, what else can it do?
Well, finally here it is! Hold on to your papers,
because scientists at DeepMind decided to start
using their MuZero AI to create a real solution
to a very important problem. Video compression.
And here comes the twist - they said, let’s
imagine that video compression is a video game.
Okay, that’s crazy, but let’s accept it for now.
But then, two questions: what are the controls,
and what is the score? How do we
know if we won video compression?
Well, the video game controller in our hand will
be is choosing the parameters of the video encoder
for each frame. Okay, but there needs to
be a score. So what is the score here?
How do we win? Well, we win if we are able to
choose the parameters such that the quality of
the output video is as good as with the previous
compression algorithms, but, the size of the video
is smaller. The smaller the output video,
the better. That is going to be our score.
And, it also uses self-competition, which
is now a popular concept in video game AIs.
This means that the AI plays against previous
versions of itself, and we measure its improvement
by it being able to defeat these previous
versions. If it can reliably do that, we
can conclude that the AI is indeed improving. This
concept works on boxing, playing catch, Starcraft
and I wonder how this would
work for video compression?
Well, let’s see. Let’s immediately
drop it into deep waters.
Yes, we are going to test this against a
mature, state of art video compression algorithm
that you are likely already using at this very
moment as you are watching this on Youtube. Well,
good luck little AI, but I’ll be honest, there
is not much hope here. These traditional video
compression algorithms are a culmination
of decades of ingenious human research.
Can a newcomer AI beat it? I am not
sure. And now, hold on to your papers,
and let’s see together. How did it go? So, a 4%
difference. So, a learning-based algorithm that
is just 4% worse than decades of human innovation?
That is great! But…wait a second, it's actually
not worse. Can it be that…yes! It is not 4% worse.
It is even 4% better. Holy mother of papers, that
is absolutely incredible. Yes, this is the corner
of the internet where we get super excited by a 4%
better solution, and understand why that matters
a great deal. Welcome to Two Minute Papers!
But wait, we are experienced Fellow Scholars
over here, we know that it is very easy to
be better by 4% in size at the cost of decreased
quality. But having the same quality and save 4%
is insanely difficult. So, which one is it? Let’s
look together. I am flicking between the state
of the art and the new technique, and, yes, my
goodness, the results really speak for themselves.
So, let’s look a bit under the hood and see
some more about the decisions the AI is making.
Whoa. That is really cool. So what is this? Here,
we see the scores for the previous technique
and the new AI, and here, they appear to be
making similar decisions on this cover song video,
but the AI makes somewhat better
decisions overall. That is very cool.
But, look at that! In the second half
of this gaming video, MuZero makes
vastly different, and, vastly
better decisions. I love it.
And to have a first crack at such a mature
problem, and manage to improve it immediately,
that is almost completely unheard of. Yet, they
have done it with protein folding, and now,
they seem to have done it for video
compression too. Bravo, DeepMind!
And note the meaning in the magnitude of the
difference here. For instance, OpenAI’s Dall-E 2
was this much better than Dall-E 1. That’s
not 4% better, if that was a percentage,
this would be several hundred percent
better. So, why get so excited about 4%?
Well, the key is that 3-4% more compression is
incredible given how well polished these state
of the art techniques are. VP9 compressors
are not some first crack at the problem,
no-no. This is a mature field
with decades of experience,
where every percent of improvement requires blood,
papers and tears, and of course, lots of compute
and memory. And this is just the first crack
at the problem for DeepMind, and we get not 1%,
but 4% essentially for free. That is absolutely
amazing. My mind is blown by this result. Wow.
And, I also wanted to thank you for watching
this video. I truly love talking about these
amazing research papers, and I am really
honored to have so many of you Fellow Scholars
who are here every episode, enjoying these
incredible works with me. It really means a lot.
Every now and then I have
to pinch myself to make sure
that I really get to do this every day.
Absolutely amazing. Thank you so much!
So, what do you think? What else could this be
useful for? What do you expect to happen
a couple more papers down the line?
Please let me know in the comments
below. I’d love to hear your thoughts.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!